i want to first find out how you're
doing in quarantine i'm finding that i'm
getting more
kid time is that the same with you yeah
absolutely yeah i mean and
it and it sucks right no no it's been
you know
listen to your heart i'm not a fan of my
family
uh yeah i don't like them um and i find
them off-putting
yeah no exactly and and knowing that i'm
50
responsible for how off-putting they are
is real humbling
i think you're not i think you're 80
responsible
certainly with my daughter you know i've
met your wife she's lovely
uh no you're you may be 90 responsible
for any negative qualities
i'm louder it's just because i'm louder
i take up more space that's all
but but yeah no we've been we've been
getting after it you know it's
it's you know our kids are uh otis is
the uh
six daisy's four and they um yeah it's
been a lot of
well with otis i've been taking them
through the classics we we you know
we've been doing star wars and
oh you watch the you watch the classic
movies that's great yeah we take we're
taking them through that because that's
that's
i'm no i'm not a good teacher you know i
i was never good at
even when i taught improv at teaching
level one i i was i was not
i'm not ted lasso in that way he's he's
a much better person and
and teacher and leader and coach than i
am but um
you know going through starting with you
know the phantom menace and working
through we're we're
you know our next one is empire strikes
back but it's been a super fun way
and very interesting way to teach and
i'm sure numerous people know this
to teach good and evil to your kids like
and just
how much they care and how much you know
to to have your
little boy like sit there and watch
anakin skywalker get more and more angry
as this you know this palpatine dude is
like you know putting you know
whispering things in his ear i mean
and i and i kind of have to be i'm
watching it with the eyes of like what's
going on in the news today i'm like oh
yeah
no palpatine's the son of a [ __ ] he
would absolutely be getting rid of
mailboxes right now
i see what i see with this slick m after
you're trying to pull
i get it i see this coming a mile away
that's a great that's a great way to
teach your kids morality i did it when
my kids were really little i made them
watch goodfellas
and uh yeah and i just basically uh so
that they could learn
that uh if the mob wants to take over
your restaurant
don't do it because they're gonna sell
and it was
it not the good lessons they needed to
learn not as clear-cut
as what you're talking about it's good
fellas not good lessons right i mean
that's that's
you know it's right there in the title
but we just watched e.t
this weekend we started too late on
saturday night thinking oh we'll do you
know wait till the dark
uh but boy our little guy
freaked out he was so sad when when the
when the spaceship spoiler
spoilers everybody if you haven't seen
e.t uh but when the spaceship takes off
and leaves e.t
on earth he freaked out in a way that
was like
i i mean i felt again eighty percent
responsible it's like i've never done
that to you i i got
immediately defensive right it's like he
like went to his bed it was just like
it's just so sad it was mostly because
he was tired because he watched it the
next day
and the whole time trying to figure out
daisy is hilarious daisy when when like
peter coyote's character shows up
with the keys and he's kind of ominous
you don't know who he is she's just like
uh oh here come the cops
[Laughter]
she knows that at what age she's three
and a half
right oh boy here come the cops there we
go hide the weed
she has all these outdated ideas yeah
speaking of kids
are your kids aware that you played a
stormtrooper in the mandalorian do they
know because that would give you the
ultimate street cred i would think otis
is definitely
we didn't we haven't watched mandalorian
we're not doing the full universe just
the you know the nine films so he hasn't
watched mandalorian yet but
um he got to come to set that day um
when i when
myself and adam pally who i know you
know we got we got that call
like i mean yeah man like the the
six to ten year old boy in me was like
yes i'll do it absolutely
and then the fact that it eventually
came out
that i um that when that thing aired and
my character
as does adam's you know punches baby
yoda yes i was going to talk about this
that hasn't come up yet i don't think
they don't know that yet but let's talk
about this
the entire internet came down on top of
you because
uh your character you as the
stormtrooper
you punch baby yoda we have that scene
right now
let's take a look waiting confirmation
pack it off and there you go
down there well there it was yeah uh
what
did you improvise that please tell me
that yeah i wish
that's what you do when you see a baby
exactly just
just haul off on a great santini style
no
like the craziest thing about that is is
you know i
did this that thing months earlier and
it was you know one afternoon
you know again truly dream come true
dressing up like that
doing it is coming down and then went
away and then did a hundred other things
you know
you know writing the ted lasso show
shooting the tele all this stuff you
know life goes on
and then they they rolled those episodes
out you know one at a time
and otis and i was sitting in here you
know playing video games or something
i forget on a saturday or sunday morning
and olivia comes in with her phone and
she goes hey you're trending on twitter
i was like oh how about that and i don't
i'm not on you know twitter like uh
actively in that way and so immediately
i was like wait why
you know in in today's age it's like
wait am i dead did i die
am i canceled what happened uh and it
was that i was being canceled in real
time that was like you
hit baby yoda and i had like that moment
like like the end of sixth sense or rat
tattooing where i'm just like
oh right i should have been able to
anticipate two and a half months earlier
when baby yoda became like the
belle of the ball you know on the
internet and everything everybody talked
about it didn't even it did i i totally
forgot that oh yeah i backhand
this little this little uh you haul off
you really wail on baby yoda and yeah
yeah
i'm it's that's a career i think that's
a career killer
i'm sorry you would think you would
think but but but because you couldn't
see my face
because people you know i can always say
that it was
you know that that they they manipulated
that i didn't know they were gonna do
that
your arm that's what yeah exactly it's
like i'll be
damned how did that happen yeah it was
all so
yeah i'm still dealing with it but i but
you know i know what jim gaffin's going
through i get it i get it